die Forderung nach mehr Geld hatte ich
nicht für begründet außer in der Schweiz
wird natürlich in Europa in den Praxen
nirgendwo so gut verdient wie in
Deutschland sicherlich ist es richtig
dass z.B bei den Hausärzten eine
entbudgetierung notwendig ist das haben
wir auch schon angekündigt dann arbeiten
wir ja das gleiche haben wir bei den
Kinderärzten auch schon gemacht aber
viele fachartsgruppen beispielsweise
Radiologen
oder Orthopäden verdienen im
internationalen Vergleich ausgezeichnet
und es hat auch wieder ein Zuwachs im
letzten Jahr gegeben somit kann ich da
die Forderung nicht sehen es gibt andere
Berufsgruppen im Gesundheitssystem
beispielsweise Pflegekräfte wo also
tatsächlich da mehr Bedarf ist aber die
Honorarforderung kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen ich weiß dass dem im Raum
steht die Entbürokratisierung das ist
eine berechtigte Forderung die seit
Jahren hätte erfüllt werden
müssen